on this episode I advance your budget a
venture budget I invite a bunch of
vaynermedia employees to ask me some
questions
[Music]
this is
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 116 of the ask gary vee
show we are now back in a vaynermedia
conference room we decided to do a
vaynermedia episode what was the last
episode that we did this on anybody know
the number 69
very good job Stefan wins the battle
where were you on that India were you
even around for episode 69 yeah and you
didn't remember yeah not a good job um
thrilled the jury duty is over pumped to
be doing the show in front of a bunch of
the vaynermedia peeps which is exciting
for me and so India let's get into the
show good job job I'm proud of you all
right let's do it who's up first
you wanna get ready is all that goes
straight sang like an wave very good
once you tell the Vayner nation who you
are and then you get the fire away my
friend my name is Dave Zhang at the
arrogance we don't worry if you watch
the show it actually pops up here it's
gonna get linked up yeah exactly my
question for you Gary is ten years from
now ten years from now industry will be
going through the most disruption so
what is gonna be like so ten years from
now so first of all and I like to say
this a lot I I don't think I'm
Nostradamus I don't like to predict I
will tell you this I'm gonna take your
question in a different place because I
don't really I mean all of them which is
really where I'm gonna go with this I
think that uber Airbnb you know these
companies that are really disrupting
markets and very hot like the hotel
industry is really disrupted by Airbnb
like the limo like if you're in a limo
business like your shits in trouble
because of uber right so these companies
I think most of us most of the people
watching think that these are anomalies
right we call them unicorns in the tech
BC world I think people think they're so
special
I actually think they're the preview I
think that every single company that is
in existence today that is not 100%
software technology-based first is
massively vulnerable and I think 10
years might be a little bit too early
but if you told me 20 30 years from now
like you know EECOM I think is much
smaller than people realize it only
represents 12 13 percent of all commerce
transactions in the u.s. that means it
has oh I don't know 88 percent to go
right so I think there's a lot of
industries I think on demand dynamics
right like laundry mats or you think are
in deep [ __ ] because I think I'm gonna
press the button somebody's gonna do my
laundry right like you look at what ship
is doing and picking up people's stuff
and like shipping it for it which I
think bodes poorly for the FedEx store I
think you can really kind of go on
anything that hasn't been disrupted by
technology really going that route and
so I think the last 10 years so much has
happened right this didn't exist 10
years ago this literally didn't exist 10
years ago I think the next 10 years will
stun people and I think people are
grossly misunderstanding the exponential
growth of technology and software eating
up our society and breaking the are the
norms that were just accustomed to it
also throw one other thing I think I
think higher education I think is
stunningly vulnerable and I don't think
it will be disrupted in 10 years but
obviously we talked about this in a
prior show I think I think once the
parents stopped caring that their kids
would go to Harvard and Yale which i
think is only one or two generations
again I think education is an
interesting place to look at make sure
man thanks cool let's go
why don't you clap for saying I like
that all right all right let's go let's
go hi how are ya I'm Molly
nice to meet you vaynernation what is
your question Molly my question is I
read an article in the New York Times
recently is that a newspaper it is the
newspaper but my mom sent it to me on
Facebook amazing so it was called no
time to be nice at work okay it's all
about how like the workplace is becoming
a hostile environment now because people
aren't civil to one
because of a bunch of external factors
they're focused on a bunch of other
different things
like what so people are nice to each
other because the pressure of day-to-day
tasks they're thinking about something
else when they're in a conversation with
somebody okay how do you find the point
of the article like what was the trying
to say it was trying to say that like
there's always time to kind of like take
a deep breath and like say hi how are
you yeah buddy
which I think you do a really good job
of okay so how do you find the time to
like focus we're having a conversation
right now this is a great example like
how do you find the time to like focus
be nice to people stay in the moment
that kind of thing how do I personally
yes I personally um you know I don't
think I really have any other gear
I truly believe like DNA and like the
way you were brought up is real like I
truly look around this room and there's
different levels of being a nice person
in this room it's just real it's just a
real thing right like like for me it's
super easy I don't so here's what I
would say I think that one thing I like
to say a lot is money and and and micro
fame real fame doesn't change a person
it just exposes a person so the amount
of people that like write me emails or
like see me in the stream like wow you
were like we'll send a tweet after they
get there take a selfie with me in the
street and they're like well Gary Vee is
a really nice guy like you actually get
credit for being a nice person the more
exposure you get which i think is silly
which i think is kind of just a weird
kind of dynamic so i think that falls in
the same realm as your question which is
you know i don't think like external
things in the world like 24/7 world like
i don't think anything's really changed
like i don't think
gertrude is nicer or meaner cuz it's
2013 and not 1955 anymore right I really
don't think though I just think Kirk
seems a bit and like decided not to be
nice just like she wouldn't have been
nice 30 years ago and so for me I don't
even know any other year as a matter of
fact I'm probably a little bit weird the
other way which is you know I'm so
uncomfortable with you know negativity
and angst at the exact nature that I
attack it and reverse a lot of my day is
is taken up trying to make sure that's
contained and not happening so it's just
my default I think there's a lot of
value in it
stunned how many people undervalue a
head nod or a hey for me because I'm as
you guys know I'm running around so much
so much of my stuff is like a wink or a
smile or it's just I don't have the time
but it's so nice like I think people
people really value effort and intent
and I think you can get away with doing
so much of that stuff with such little
stuff right and so for me it's easy
because my parents had sex at the right
moment to give me my DNA and Thank You
Kim and and my mom my mom really you
know parented me in a way to really
value other people and and all that kind
of stuff and so I just haven't known any
different I love that I get like extra
credit for it nowadays because a couple
of people follow me on social media but
for me there's you know and and and more
importantly and I think you know this
and I think a lot of you know this and
some of you don't know this but it's
what's more interesting to me is I
believe in it's so much
the level of which I'm forcing it down
below me not just leading by example but
being pretty upfront with senior
leadership of how much it matters to me
is a I think helps our company well I'm
well I'm Merve fantasy sports the daily
fantasy sports market is blown up lately
draftkings by disney sports how do you
think that changes the game for us as
fans and its marketers does it shift us
more to being fans of players instead of
teams and his loyalty guard good
question I am if so if Tom Brady's leg
fell off his body today in the news I'd
be happy right I'm more than happy to
say that I understand how that's
disgusting as a human being but it's the
truth so I'm just telling the truth
if tomorrow Tom Brady got traded to the
Jets I would love him with all my heart
so you're talking to somebody who
completely and utterly 100% all-in only
roots for the logo not the player video
games sports memorabilia and now more
than ever fantasy sports has clearly
created a culture I had a family event
unfortunately a
a negative family event but but 19 my
Liz's 99 year old grandmother passed
away we had a ceremony before noon and
what Liz's cousin was there he's young
and he's a Seahawks fan and we're
sitting in the living room and
SportsCenter comes up and Peyton Manning
comes up he's like yeah he's like 9 or
11 yeah Peyton Manning the man I love
you pigmenting and I looked and I said
your Seahawks fan like you pleading each
other in the Super Bowl he's like yeah
but in the pink Manning fantasy if I'm
touching that I was like this sucks like
I hate like the coat for me and I'm by
the way this whole show for 116 episodes
I say don't be romantic don't be
romantic don't be romantic and that's
because I think business like it's a
very deadly sin in sports
I am outrageously romantic it's the one
place where I think I'm the worst
version of myself and it is stunning for
me how much I hate player culture where
like you are a Giants fan but you like a
cowboy player like it makes no sense of
me I've been in environments one of the
great things that has ever happened to
me on this issue was I was at a sports
bar before a Jets game because I could
never be at a bar setting for a Jets
game but before a Jets game there was a
Giants fan wearing an Eli Manning Jersey
and the Giants were killing the Eagles
and a random touchdown by DeSean Jackson
happens and the giant fan goes yeah and
I looked at him and said you are a piece
of I'm like how in the world did he's
like this Sean's on my fantasy team so
this was the game several years ago
where the Eagles had a furious comeback
in the fourth quarter and the Sean
Jackson had the kickoff and scored and
the Eagles came back and won that game
after being down led by like three
touchdowns I was so happy a happiness
that I can't even explain that that guy
got it stuck to him for cheering for a
fantasy thing over his favorite football
team but that's something I'm romantic
about so how do I think I think most of
the kids these days and even the
grown-ups are getting rewired to be more
player centric I think that's really
dangerous for the league's you want to
talk about something that could happen
in 10 to 20 to 30 years I truly believe
before I die the 5 to 15 most
influential athletes within a league
will go out and start
a separate league and pull it off before
I die I believe that will happen and I
think that's super interesting tying
question one to tell question three on
this episode because I think that
they're gaining disproportionate
leverage the cost of entry of
distribution TV rights is changing and I
think there'll be smart business people
that will come in and pay them to go
start that league and change the
dynamics I think it's a very slippery
slope for the league's to go down this
path but they will because the money is
short-term and they'll take it good
Jim Francis months two at vaynermedia
yes MERP you're also month what one two
what happened some newbies on the show
okay so one of the things I love most
about being here hustle amazing okay
what are your suggestions when working
with external partners who you got to
work with to get the job done yeah who
don't share your hustle
you mean like the rest of the entire
world you know I and from an agency
dynamic we're stuck right like like you
want to look good in the sandbox which
for people that don't understand you you
know you work with a brand you got four
or five six three different agency
partners and it's important that you
know what a brand hates that we work
with this when the agencies are playing
politics with each other because their
assumption is that we as vain are trying
to get the money of this person and that
makes sense that's a cynical point of
view that's the right point of view by
the way ninety percent of the time and
so I and you may not fully know this but
some of the people that have been here a
little bit longer I'm actually very
aggressive like don't go down that route
we'll get ours by just showing what
we're about but it makes it frustrating
for all of you that are in the trenches
because I'm probably taking I'm probably
pushing it even too far of like be nice
to everybody even though they suck or do
you think they suck and so I get it I
think everyone sucks and so I I think
that um I think that it's it's a
balancing act right it's a really fine
tightrope i I think letting your work
speak for itself is a very smart
strategy I think the truth is undefeated
meaning I do think eventually the truth
bubbles up right now you may have a
flawed
of the truth you know like the there's a
human being that runs that brand that
may not see it may be tricked may have
too much romance for the prior world or
logos over team players and so I think
that uh I think you have to assess who
the judge or D is number one cuz that's
just the real game I think you need to
build a relationship for real outside of
what's happening in the room with those
people because let's not forget they're
just humans that work for a company and
I have found that a lot of times they
realize they stink too because maybe
their company stinks and at least that
at least gets you aligned where you're
not mad at the person you're mad at logo
which I think often times takes a lot of
venom out of this situation makes it all
more palpable so I think when it comes
down to is good old-fashioned
communication on all levels your own
team somebody's a little more senior one
of the things that we struggle with here
at Vayner is the youngsters don't fully
get it all the way they haven't been
through it so they're looking just at
the narrow like this project isn't done
at Thursday at 4:00 they think like
there's a lot more going on than that so
I think communication with your team to
the side the different players the
client just communication communication
communication thank you you got a very
selfish question Thanks
I'm just kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding
I'm not moving do you rock let's go
again short you move [ __ ]
hey vaynernation my name is Jody Gowen
nice to meet you haven't we met you um
all right so we talked a lot about press
and the pros and cons of getting press
on but even in like bad press situations
someone won't like some troll will
always bring up the argument like well
at least we're talking about it right
right lot of like all press is good
press yep
what's your thoughts on that I agree or
disagree fundamentally disagree like if
somebody said you're a murderer
and a child molester if you think that's
good if you think that's good press
you're out of your [ __ ] mind
right so like the thought that all press
is good press is ludicrous everything
matters contextually it's the same
reason I feel crazy about media in our
world
everybody thinks all impressions are
equal they're not like the content
matters like the way people feel about
you matters if they think like I'm
adamantly against that
and I think that's I think the people
that say all press is good press are
people that get bad press look like I
really do like like I can't wrap my head
around like bad press being a good thing
like how that completely does the thing
that pisses me the most off about media
it takes the context out of the equation
well you still reached 11 million people
like really like like Donald Trump's
getting a shitload of press right now do
we think that's good like who could
possibly think that's good like that's a
crazy thought and so I think that's a
that's a massive misnomer and I'm I'm
very disrespectful to anybody that
believes that to be true Johnny right
thank you you got didn't big child
molester was gonna get dropped on this
anything yeah bonus crash let's go wise
on the bonus question okay
I love improv what was either your first
or your most embarrassing screaming one
of my al chat names way back in the day
was G nuts with a Z GE e and you t'see
that uh that one is a good one
that is a that is your answer Allison
not bad for an improv go country yeah
job awesome man
appreciate the live audience give a
little give it a little get it with a
little camera action for everybody
hey guys hope you guys all have a good
fourth of July G nuts is signing off
for the 4th of July question of the day
how badly do you want to work here you
keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
thanks guys
[Applause]